I had a very interesting day talking to
people here about their science and
catching up on some of the latest things
that are going on here at Carnegie
Mellon and some of it overlaps with some
of the things that I talked about that
I'll be talking about so when you hear
them talk perhaps some of the things
that I mentioned we'll put a little bit
in perspective so I've chosen this it's
a fairly elaborate title I'm a condensed
matter physicist a theorist and
sometimes called solid-state physics and
my job is to predict the existence and
properties of new materials and to try
to explain what the experimentalists
measure so they'll bring these wonderful
experimental data to me and I try to
make sense of it or I can say if you do
this this will happen so it's it's
really a very wonderful life to be in a
position to do this and mainly I do it
with the aid of excellent graduate
students and through models that I work
on
mostly pencil and paper and the great
proficiency of this next generation with
computers were able to achieve these
aims one of the most important concepts
in all of science is that macroscopic
matter is made of atoms the concept of
an atom goes back to the Greeks but the
actual picture of what an atom look like
developed over time in particular
Thompson discovered the electron and the
electron was negative so he knew it had
to come out of a positive region because
atoms are neutral and he pictured an
atom as a pudding of positive nature and
these plums in the puddings were the
electrons that he pulled out it's not
such a bad model it's not our current
model but it's not so bad
for explaining some of the properties of
let's say metals
then around Newton's time they knew that
atoms would bind together and form
solids so they pictured atoms as having
hooks and so the idea is how do you put
atoms together so that they'll form
solids and the way we do it nowadays is
through the quantum theory so I'm going
to tell you a little bit about what a
quantum atom looks like or try to give
you an impression of it and then talk
about how you put this together now as
Fred mentioned in 2005 I was president
American Physical Society and it
happened to be the year of physics
worldwide and we were celebrating the
hundredth anniversary of Einstein's Mac
miraculous year in 1905 when he did
incredibly wonderful things working in a
patent office and you many of you know
the stories and he was determined to
establish the existence of atoms at that
point people were still arguing about
whether atoms existed and he actually
worked on the determination of molecular
dimensions he also worked on Brownian
motion which is if you suspend particles
in the air they'll be bumped around by
molecules shows that molecules actually
exist items actually exist and then
relativity and finally which you know
about and I'll say something more about
it and the photoelectric effect this
effect is you shine light on a metal
surface and electrons pop out turned out
to be an extremely important experiment
and his theory was very important
because it showed that the light that
came in could behave as a wave but it
could also behave as a particle so the
photons which are associated with the
concept of light went in and bumped
electrons out of the material came out
in fact this is the work that he
received the Nobel Prize for but it
wasn't always so easy for n Stein he had
several attempts
in trying to get his thesis subject to
prove for example he went to Professor
Dr Weber around 1900 and he proposed
that we should measure the speed of
light in different directions and later
this experiment was done by Michelson
and this was the first Nobel Prize for
an American but professor Weber rejected
that as an idea for a thesis so I hope
their students out there that can
identify with this kind of thing but he
went back and he proposed to work on the
effect of how heat changes the
electrical conductivity of solids and
the conductance of solids and this is a
very important problem particularly now
in electronics and unfortunately Weber
didn't see the use of this so he tried
again and he took the other approach
with he said let's look at how heat
flows through solids and he developed
the theory and he wanted to use that for
his thesis but he wrote it on the wrong
kind of paper Weber was angry by this
point nobody really felt in stein was an
Einstein and so he said no so he went to
Professor dr. kleiner and he wanted to
talk about a very and work on a very
important problem which is you take
gases and you have isolated atoms and
you bring them closer and closer
together so the atoms start interacting
with one another and they form a liquid
and then you squeeze more in to become a
solid so you want to work on
inter-atomic forces and intermolecular
forces and this is a fundamental problem
and Kleiner must have talked to Weber
and didn't work and then this was a big
mistake by your professor dr. kleiner
because Einstein proposed to him that he
wanted to work on the electrodynamics of
moving bodies this led this is my cereal
bowl which my wife gave me
a is for whatever Apple B is for ball C
is for car D is for dog and a equals
mc-squared
and that could have been the kleiner
Einstein equation but kleiner
didn't see the light and he rejected
finally he did some theoretical work to
explain properties of sugar molecules
and wrote this up as a dissertation
because it gave people the chance to
measure the sizes of molecules and to
establish that atoms really existed and
included kleiner and Burkhardt they said
it was too short 17 pages he added one
sentence and that was his thesis now
Einstein went on of course to do
miraculous things but a lot of these
miraculous things were based on the
things that he thought about as a
student and during that wonderful year
of 1905 he successfully worked on this
now the big revolution in physics in
this part of physics came with the
development of quantum mechanics and
that happened in the 1920s and by 1929
Dirac proposed the following challenge
he said we've given you the underlying
physical laws necessary for a large part
of physics and all of chemistry and he
said now what you have to do is take
these complicated equations and solve
them and basically my talk today is a
report and what's happened in the past
83 years and how the quantum mechanical
theory can be reduced to a form where
you can actually solve things so the
difficulty is that for a quantum atom
instead of having these atoms with hooks
or plums and puddings you have a nucleus
which was discovered by Rutherford and
then the electrons that are important
for building solids
or around the outside and they're fuzzy
and in fact you can't tell exactly where
they are but you can tell with great
precision the probability of finding
electron densities at certain points so
the theory is based on looking at the
probability density for electrons and
the question is how do you take a system
like that put those things together and
make solids out of them and there is a
philosophical aspect to this that I
thought I'd bring up because many
physicists are talking about this
although usually when you talk about
philosophy of science physicists sort of
leave the room saying that the
philosophers don't know what's going on
but this argument has been going on and
it's and it's interesting to look at it
in the light of this field of condensed
matter physics so I want to put these
atoms together and I want to get a
mental picture of what a solid is like
and there's two fundamental models that
have developed over the years one is
that the atoms just interact with each
other so I should start with the atoms
and see how they're changed and another
one is called the elementary excitation
model and I'll tell you what that is in
a moment in the interacting atoms model
you say a solid is a collection of
strongly interacting atoms and from the
philosophers point of view this is
called reductionism if I say I know the
particles are these nuclei and electrons
I know that the interact through
electromagnetic interactions because the
other interactions that gravity and so
forth are too weak on this level this is
the appropriate system and so I should
be able to start from atoms and tell
everything and so this is one approach
and as Fred mentioned the pseudo
potential what the pseudo potential does
is if I line up my atoms in some
specific order then the nuclei will
which is the dark part at the center I
think this has a laser on it
anyway is it China okay
the nucleus is this dark part it doesn't
really make much difference when you
form a solid for the nucleus it doesn't
change very much so there are core
electrons for example if this is silicon
it has ten electrons this is very close
to the core and they don't change very
much
and then those extra four electrons form
this fuzzy soup that make up the
properties of the solid so in fact if I
can calculate the energy of this whole
thing and then move these atoms around
and look for the lowest energy nature
always wants the lowest energy I can
tell you the structure of silicon
knowing only the number of electrons and
how the electrons interact with the core
and that's the pseudo potential and we
can build the pseudo potential for any
atom in the periodic table when you
teach solid-state physics you talk about
silicon in diamond and so this is a an
old view graph and you say that each
silicon atom is surrounded by four other
silicon atoms and this is the same thing
whether if this were carbon and that
would be diamond it's a very strong bond
there's a ball and stick model these are
those atoms and those are the sticks and
the sticks of the valence electrons well
now you can go in theoretically and
calculate where the electrons are and as
I mentioned it's a probability so the
probability density is that the
electrons will pile up halfway between
the two silicon atoms and form the bond
and this is an honest theoretical piece
of work because it came before the
experiment and the experiment came
afterward and you can see the
similarities between the covalent bond
so this is one of the strongest bonds in
nature it's a covalent bond and although
this is for silicon it would look
similar for other materials so with this
method using this approach for a broad
class of solids and clusters and
molecules and the rest we can tell you
where the electrons are
we can actually predict crystal
structures because we can actually tell
you how far apart the atoms will be by
choosing the lowest energy and we can
get this whole list this is the
commercial of properties many properties
so at one point we were labeled quantum
alchemists in other words this is a
picture drawn by Roz Chast who usually
does cartoons for those of you who read
The New Yorker you've seen her cartoons
and she pictured the quantum alchemists
is having all these kinds of things but
actually all you need is a graduate
students and computers and this was at a
time when we were looking at the
possibility of making things that are
harder than diamond now from the
philosophical point of view there's
another approach and it's actually a
practical approach and that is if I
claim that all I know about the solid
this is a picture of the solid is what I
measure and if I probe the solid I'll
measure different things and then what
goes on in the black box is something
that I can think of in another way so
let me give you an example if I shine
light on a solid and I want to know how
the solids reacting I measure the
reflectivity and when I measure the
reflectivity if I can explain that
reflectivity in terms of fictitious
particles let's say I didn't know that
it was made of electrons and so forth
then I have a theory and you may say
that that's cheating
but I'll I'll take you further along
here let's say I put temperature in I
measure the heat capacity which is how
the solid heats up when how much energy
goes in when I raise the temperature or
I can put on a magnetic field or
whatever so the idea is this picture has
a probe and you measure the response and
the idea is that particles that explain
the properties emerge
and this is emergence theory
so the philosopher would say that the
earlier model where I put atoms together
is called a reductionist
model and the emergent model is like a
model that biologists use where does
life come from well it emerges you put
all this stuff together and all of a
sudden that says lo and you have
consciousness and life well here for
example if we talk about hitting the
solid with a hammer the atoms are going
to vibrate and they'll produce sound
waves and you can think of those sound
waves as particles called phonons and
those phonons become real to you because
you can explain the properties all the
responses in terms of these photons an
excellent example is the concept of a
hole if you have 10 to the 23rd
electrons per cubic centimeter that's 10
you know all the way out in in a
semiconductor and you take one out you
shine light and take one out it's a lot
more convenient to talk about the
absence of that electron as a positive
hole lectrons are negative and think of
how the hole moves then to look at how
all the 10 to the 21st now you know I
can't throw a hole across the room
whereas principle you can throw an
electron across the room but engineers
in Silicon Valley spend their whole
lives on holes these fictitious
particles so the question is what's real
is that hole real is that a way of
describing nature and what do we know
well back around the turn of the century
there was a lot going on in discussions
of this kind and in particular our
barracks and talked to I'm sign a lot
about these things barracks in and talk
to Einstein a great deal because he
didn't believe in the theory of
relativity and eventually Einstein
convinced them it was true Ericsson had
made some he was a French mathematician
and made some important contributions to
mathematics and then once he got into
science he started thinking about
science philosophy and he said
everything we sense our images
it's through our senses so depending on
how you describe it you have to describe
turns and images and so he is sort of
one of the fathers of emergence and this
is being debated by the way he went on
to get a Nobel Prize in Literature so he
was a very talented person who worked in
many areas and Einstein when he wrote
his Nobel Prize paper in 1905 and the
photoelectric effect he it was called
considering the generation and
transformation of light from a heuristic
point of view he really met that this
was a model and it was very much
emergent properties he didn't go through
all the various details and he was more
interested in the concept that life
could behave as a particle or a wave
even though he couldn't picture it so in
a sense it was an emergent point of view
and he went back and forth between
emergence and reductionism through his
life I thought I'd mentioned it because
these questions are being discussed by
physicists nowadays and what's the most
appropriate way thing to do and in my
field that turns out you need both so
I'll just mention and I won't go into
detail on photovoltaics even though
people are working on that here but
Einstein's theory of photoemission
looking at how electrons pop out of
surfaces is very useful for calculating
how to make better photo electrics our
problem is that this is the solar
spectrum and silicon is the most used
material for photovoltaics so you want
silicon to absorb a lot of sunlight in
this energy range you see a dozen and
once it absorbs the light then that
turns into electrons and holes and this
gives you a current so if you can modify
silicon so that it absorbs light in that
range you do much better
and using these techniques we are now
able to do that and so it's very helpful
from a practical point of view okay
nanoscience I was at the Physical
Society American Physical Society
meeting in Boston last week and the most
discussed topics were nanoscience and
super conductivity so I thought I'd tell
you a little bit about it nanoscience
just means that we're studying things on
the nanometer scale 10 to the minus
ninth of a meter and this is a scale
which is of interest to physicists the
chemist material scientists biologists
engineers computer scientists because
this is a scale where you make devices
this is a scale where the biologists are
working for many of the things that are
important for biology and this is
roughly the scale of the nanotubes and
there's atoms and DNA is here and all
the rest and so that has brought us
together it's actually broken down walls
between departments years ago the
Department of Energy would give us extra
money if we would work with chemists and
we said we would but we didn't we took
the money now we work with chemists that
we work with biologists because
molecular motors and nano motors are
similar and the latest rage is graphene
this was a Nobel Prize for 2011 if you
took your pencil lead and looked at it
closely you find that it's a series of
layers I'm sorry a series of layers that
look like this this is an actual picture
using an electron microscope
so there are hexagons there's an atom
here and atom here an atom here and
notice oh these are carbon atoms but
instead of having 3 4 neighbors like a
dozen diamond like I showed you before
car
has the unusual property that it can
also have three neighbors and be a
layered material and that's why we're
alive because carbon can form these
multiple bonds silicon can't and it can
form these multiple bonds and make
organic compounds and so it forms these
layers and in your pencil when you write
these layers come off and that's what
the writing is so these very very
strongly bonded layers are connected
very weakly to each others one stack on
top of another and they rub off from one
another and so what happened was people
wanted to work just on the layers they
didn't know how to peel it off and to
researchers I'll give you their names
later took scotch tape put it on top of
graphite which is pencil led and peeled
it off and got individual layers and
then very soon after got the Nobel Prize
so this is what a picture of what a
layer of graphene would look like all
these hexagons and if you cut out the
appropriate geometry you can bend them
around and make a buckyball which is a
60 atom molecule or if you just roll up
a piece of and nature does this for you
of graphene you make a carbon nanotube
and you can look at graphene ribbons
which is slices of these people can cut
these out and single layer by layer and
so forth and this is the current rate so
I'll give you an example of a nanotube
calculation which has been shown to be
correct if you take a nano take a sheet
of graphene and you've been eight you go
around eight layers eight hexagons and
don't move it up or down just come
around like that that will be a
semiconductor and if you go around seven
times and push up by one AD by one
hexagon that'll be a metal that's how
versatile these materials are
and you can put them together so that
you have a metal semiconductor interface
if instead of having six and six you
have same number of atoms but five and
seven in this form something called a
Schottky barrier which is an electronic
device that you can build radios and so
forth out of it so on a very small scale
you can create devices and do all kinds
of things now there are wild things that
people want to do with nanotubes and
I'll tell you about one you want to make
a space elevator the idea in the old
days was to try to build a tower to the
moon but they realize materials weren't
strong enough and then Sir Arthur Clarke
the science fiction writer said that you
could get satellites going around the
earth and you put them in the right
orbit they'll stay right over one place
in other words as the Earth rotates it
will stay there so you can put one on
above Carnegie Mellon you know all you
have to do is build a cable and you can
take things up and bring things down and
all the rest and so there is a project
primarily at Los Alamos to make a space
elevator using carbon nanotubes and
trying to see whether or not they can
take things up and down and they want to
have one going around Mars and put
things down and up if you actually
calculate the strength of the carbon
nanotube which is about the strongest
material in the world if you pull it
this way you find it's about a tenth of
the you know it's a tenth of the
strength that you need to even have
something that long but they're trying
to weave these things and do all kinds
of things so I don't know about this
project but I'll show you a project that
does work and it's very interesting the
carbon nanotubes actually sometimes form
is a single cylinder but they often form
like these Russian dolls a cylinder
within a cylinder within a cylinder
concentric cylinders and the
experimentalists can reach in and pull
out one of the cylinders and let it pop
back in and so forth
now the cylinders themselves because the
bonds are very strong they retain their
identity they're very good but between
the cylinders as I said in graphite is
very weak so this has almost no friction
so it's like a frictionless bearing and
so the idea is to make a motor out of it
so first I'll show you the schematic of
how you make a motor and then I'll show
you a real one you take a carbon
nanotube in this case it's a it's a
multi wall - it's got two tubes and one
inside the other and you put it down on
the surface and the yellow is gold and
you configure it so it has a little
piece of gold on it and then these are
just electrodes and if you go inside and
look at what's happening inside the tube
you'll see that there's an outer tube
and then there's an inner tube and and
these tubes like to form in as by tubes
having two tubes and so you pulse this
gold piece of gold to make the thing
turn and you break these bonds so the
outer tube moves around separately from
the inner tube and if you put on
electrical contacts by changing the
positive negative positive negative
you've actually made a motor and this is
what a real one looks like if you the
tube is going up the center this was the
first one made some years ago and they
now make them by the hundreds and so
there's a tube going down there this is
a piece of gold piece of gold and it can
go them around and they're applying it
in various ways so this to give you an
idea of the scale this little motor
could fit on the back of a virus it's
that small and they can engineer it and
they can make them even smaller nowadays
new direction on nanotubes that's taking
up much of my time and other people is a
boron nitride nanotubes
instead of having all carbon atoms here
you take a book replace one by one
another one by nitrogen and this is a
very very strong tube and it's a
semiconductor but you can dope it and
when you have these tubes and you dope
it the electrons go right down the
center of the two so you can build a
pipe for electrons and they can they've
used it for flat panel displays and for
many applications I'll show you some
applications in a moment but one of the
things that's been a lot of fun and I'll
tell you why it's important a little bit
later is that you can get these c60
buckyballs inside the center of the two
now this is a multi wall - it's probably
got about six or eight walls so that's
why you're seeing a bunch of lines
because you've seen cross-section and
these are c60 molecules lined up and
depending on the diameter of the hole
you can get different configurations so
this is schematic for example if the
buckyball or these ball bearings are the
same size as the tube then they line up
like this if it's a little bit bigger
they start doing this and the
mathematicians have worked out all the
different structures you can get so
these are structures that are not in
nature but you can build them and you
can make them do all kinds of things art
precedes science here this is a man ray
the famous photographer and I actually
saw the actual piece that he made this
was back in the 30s in in Seoul at the
Museum in in Seoul and as you can see he
anticipated this their science is
sometimes behind art okay I'm just going
to mention that we're expecting a lot
from these boron nitride tubes and the
only problem is how to make a lot of
them and there's some been some new
technique so that they come out like
this the nice thing is they're extremely
strong mechanically and
you can make fibers that's a glove so
that's the size of a hand you can make
yarns and textiles you can they can't
get dirty and because it's white you can
actually dye them carbon nanotubes are
black and they're using them for medical
therapy because Boren absorbs neutrons
and gets hot so if you put them in the
body and get them to a place where
there's a tumor people have destroyed
tumors using these tubes they're bio
friendly in that we haven't found any
reports of them causing damage whereas
you do have damage with carbon nanotubes
and they're using them for storing
hydrogen and lithium so they want to use
them for batteries and all the rest so
this these are some practical aspects of
these tubes and I'm happy to report that
we were able to predict the existence of
the tubes just using this quantum
alchemy approach and my colleague
colleagues at all-that Berkeley was able
to make them so it was unrig i'm and
co-ceo of Novosel EV who won the nobel
prize in 2011 sorry 2010 but this table
that they made up was in 2011 and people
keep showing it because they're trying
to explain why graphene is so exciting
and why so many people are working on it
well it's the thinnest imaginable
material because it's one atom thick has
a large surface there it's the strongest
material ever measured this is
theoretically because you can't really
grab graphene and pull it but it's got
to be the strong it's stiff its
stretchable it does all these things so
I'm going to just show you one of the
reasons why graphene is exciting and
I'll just give you a quick example but I
won't go into details if you take an
ordinary electron and ask what its
energy is as you increase its momentum
the energy goes as the momentum squared
and the electrons in a metal the energy
goes this could be momentum K go as a
square of the energy and then you fill
up all the electrons
something called a Fermi level and then
it's empty above and you excite
electrons from here to here you know
semiconductor is also quadratic it goes
as the momentum squared and there's a
gap and you take electrons from here and
you put in here and this is the gap that
silicon has that gives you the
photoelectric effect but for graphite or
graphene there is no gap at zero and the
energy is linear in the momentum and so
people have gone back they said the
physics is totally different but Dirac
had an equation a relativistic equation
for the energy as a function of the
momentum and the mass so for example if
you had no momentum that East squared
would be M Squared C to the fourth so e
equals mc-squared
but once you put momentum in for a
massless particle ego's this pc so it
goes linearly and this does an amazing
amount of changes things considerably of
course now it's not the velocity of
light because this is in a solid and
it's the velocity of light over about
300 so it's this funny property that
allows you to do strange things and I'm
just going to tell you two strange
things but I won't explain it all if you
take a piece of graphite and you draw
lines on it and it's possible to draw a
line perpendicular and then you shine
electrons no matter what angle they come
in they go straight they don't go along
the lines but perpendicular lines they
go straight so you can take a graphene
sheet and culminate electrons and make
let's say flat panel displays and all
the rest another strange thing because
of these special properties of graphene
is if you cut a ribbon of it so these
are just carbon atoms hexade and then
the electrons have spin and because of
the nature of graphene at one end the
spins will all line up up at the other
one in the line up down and if you
usually you change the direction of the
spin with a magnetic field but here
with an electric field you can get all
the electrons lines straight up or all
the electrons line straight down so you
can polarize electrons and that's a very
important aspect so I just wanted to say
that graphene is different and there's a
lot of reasons for studying it okay now
last topic is super conductivity it was
discovered in 1911 so last year was the
hundredth year anniversary and we
celebrated it all all around the world
and it was discovered by come early
illness in Leiden and there are many
stories about whether he was around when
it was discovered because his students
were there in the lab and then tried to
convince him that it was there but there
are many versions of this and it's
discussed in physics today but basically
he had liquefied helium which allows you
to go to temperatures down to around 4
degrees Kelvin this is on the Kelvin
scale very very cold
and they measured the resistance of
mercury and instead of it coming back to
a constant it went to zero really zero
and even in those days they could
measure this to 10 to the minus 5 ohms
and found that it was zero so no
resistance it flows without resistance
that means and this experiment was done
soon after that if you took a piece of
metal made up just this is just a metal
wire and you got a super current going
in and you kept it cold that current
would continue forever if you calculate
how long forever is it's longer than the
age of the universe before this thing
would decay so because electrons making
a current going around in a circle
produce a magnetic field you could carry
a magnetic field from one place to
another and I forget who the first
person was to take a ring of this from
Leiden and took it took it over to
England but the problem is you have to
keep it cold and had to be liquid helium
and Onis attended this very famous of a
conference in 1911 it had some of the
greatest physicists of the time there's
Marie Curie easy to pick out because
there's only one woman here is max
planck who started quantum mechanics
Sommerfeld who was one of the leaders in
my field rutherford who discovered the
nucleus and that's kamerlingh honest and
he's a very happy man because this was
in the fall of nineteen eleven and he
discovered superconductivity in the
spring of nineteen eleven and he's
standing next to mine Stein and it's
clear that he told Einstein about super
conductivity and it's clear that
Einstein said because he said in later
years no one would ever figure it out
something like that because he said it's
a complicated cooperation between
molecules and how are you gonna do and
all the rest and he actually wrote some
papers well it took 46 years to get a
theory of superconductivity for the
material that illness discovered and for
materials like that and I'll tell you
about that and we have a class of
materials today that are not understood
so what happened after onus was here's
the transition temperature in the Kelvin
scale if dry ice is about 200 so it's
way way up there so this is where
America
sorry mercury was discovery and this is
helium and it climbed at a third of a
degree per year the highest temperature
and sort of sat around here in this
range of about 20 degrees and then in
1987 1986 87 this superconducting copper
oxides were discovered and they're much
much higher in fact above liquid air
temperatures so that in fact you could
take and we all went off to high schools
to do this this is a picture of a
training in its city
on so-called one-two-three material
between barium copper oxide I'm sorry
these are sitting on these are magnets
on the bottom of the train and then
there's a high-temperature
superconductor you pour nitrogen on and
then the Train levitates and there are
real trains in various places that
people have experimented with that can
levitate
but the idea is that you have to keep
them cold well the problem is that we
understand the theory of these materials
which I'm going to call class one
materials and but these materials class
two although many people have theories
there's no consensus so the Solway
people actually got a bunch of us
theoreticians together in 2008 to try to
reproduce in the same building the
metropole hotel and all the rest to
solve this problem of superconductivity
and of course nobody we were not able to
my wife points out that all week
everybody was dressed in their usual
terrible clothes but when it came time
for the picture they all appeared like
this and everybody just wanted to stand
where Einstein stood but it turned out
it was a they found they were very upset
when they found out it was a different
room and so there was a cartoon in The
New Yorker they happened to come out
just then it says can we start over at
like 1987 is the theorists talking to a
psychiatrist because they still from
still till today we don't really have a
good theory for those class 2
superconductors but one thing we know
and that is that like the class 1
superconductors and that theory was
explained by bardeen cooper and
schrieffer in 1957
we know that the electrons are paired so
the question is why if you pair
electrons will the electrons go through
a wire and not lose energy why is that
superconducting and to explain this you
think about going to a dance
and you and your partner are going to
dance about 15 feet apart from each
other long distance so there'll be other
couples between you and all the rest but
you know who your partner is and
whenever you move forward your partner
moves forward you move back
your partner moves back I mean that's
the agreement and when you bump off
something even though your partner
doesn't have something to bump off your
partner bumps off the opposite way so as
these electrons move no matter what
happens to them the partner if one loses
momentum the partner picks it up and so
all you need to create super
conductivity from this bardeen cooper
Schriever theory is for the electrons to
match up to attract each other and
electrons are negative so they repel
each other but it turns out in the
bardeen cooper Schriever theory you can
activate the lattice those phonons I
talked about and one electron will pull
the lattice in such a way that when the
second electron comes by it tries to
follow it and it looks like the
electrons are attracted to each other or
as we used to explain it in the 1960s if
you put two ball bearings on a waterbed
that'll make depressions and they'll
come together so the one of the ball
bearings will see the depression of the
other one have fallen so they polarized
the lattice so that's the theory and if
you divide all of superconductors into
these two classes the first one even
metal convention metals organics
magnesium de board which is about a 40
degree superconductor highest in this
class they all fall into this category
and we know what binds them here we
don't really understand them that's
class two so the bottom line is every
single experiment that's ever been done
that I know about on class one
superconductors has been explained and
there's no consensus of the mechanism
for class two now so if you understand
class one
can you explain it from first principles
or even predict them and I'm happy to
say that we're able to predict many of
the class once several of the class one
superconductors and we just have to know
essentially one thing this is a formula
for the temperature went for a
superconducting transition in the
important thing to realize is that this
lambda is the strength of the electrons
coupling to the lattice
that's what's forming the pairs this is
the repulsive Coulomb interaction you
can forget about all the others and this
is the frequency that the lattice
vibrates so if I know the frequency the
lattice vibrates and I know how strongly
the electron couples to the lattice I
can give you the transition temperature
cuz we can calculate this and in fact it
gets even simpler if lambda is really
strong if you want to make a really high
TC superconductor let's say room
temperature which is what the holy grail
for this field if everyone is trying to
get the higher temperatures then it
really just all you need to know is the
strength electron and strength and the
phonon frequency and it's just the
square root of that so let me quickly
tell you that in the early days we could
predict that some materials would be
superconducting using semi empirical
approaches but now in fact we can start
along the lines at the beginning of the
lecture with this quantum alchemy we
could predict that silicon even under
high pressure will become a metal we can
predict its structure we can predict
everything about it its existence its
stability its lattice constants
and even its super conductivity and the
only thing you have to put in is the
atomic number and the atomic mass of
silicon and these estimates and so these
new silicon materials which didn't exist
before they were predicted theoretically
were found and they're superconducting
but they're not really very high
temperatures so question is
how can you get since you understand
class 1 can you get the higher
transition temperatures and this would
be the last subject so we want large
lambdas we want the electrons to couples
strongly to the lattice we don't want it
too large because it will distort the
lattice will go unstable and you'll lose
the effect so we avoid stabilities by
going to cage structures where the
system is held together by something
else I'm going back to this for example
these boron nitride nanotubes we've put
in the c6 these and now they're putting
potassium in and the potassium is
interacting with the c6 he's trying to
get a higher transition temperature so
I'll just give you the bottom line on
the latest work I'm trying to get the
high temperature superconductors I
mentioned that the transition
temperature goes like the square root of
this lambda parameter times the phonons
it turns out that that's the same as an
electronic spring constant that we can
calculate it's very strong for strongly
bonded materials divided by the mass of
the atom square root of this gives you
the transition temperature so we're
looking for things that have strong
bonds and like masses and that brings us
all the way back to diamond but diamond
is an insulator so you have to get
carriers in and people are doping
diamond and the first discovery is were
in the in Russia and they got it to 4
degrees now they're up to 11 degrees and
there's a big effort trying to get
higher and we can show that if you look
at the transition temperature this is an
old picture but it shows that the
transition temperature is functional and
that keeps going up the early theory
said it would stop but we know that this
is correct goes like the square root of
lambda and some of the predictions give
super conductivity in diamond could go
up even to room temperature but there's
a problem when you make predictions as
Yogi Berra said predicting is difficult
especially about
future and up to this point the highest
temperature superconductors are these
copper oxides and I can't tell you how
to make them higher temperature because
we don't understand them
and now we have new systems that are in
getting up to that range with iron in it
and they are also in the class two
regions so we only can explain the class
one so to sum up our standard model is
interacting atoms and elementary
excitations we need to use both in
understanding solids and nowadays
theorists can explain and even predict
ground state or excited state properties
of many condensed matter systems but all
decisions and physics are made by
experiment but maybe with these new
techniques we'll be able to predict new
states of matter and maybe get a jump on
experimentalist and the question comes
up in my field often the work is very
basic and it's as basic as it is in
other areas of physics but sometimes
it's applied because we work with
semiconductors and all the rest and so
when a student asks if light is a
particle or a way you give the same
answer for that as you say should I do
basic or applied science the correct
answer is yes and and because they feed
on each other and sometimes the
applications push you in a new direction
for basic science and vice-versa and a
question of basic science and when it's
useful when William Gladstone was the
English finance minister he later became
the Prime Minister of England he said to
Michael Faraday who is an extraordinary
experimentalist and did the early work
on electricity well what is the
practical use of electricity and Faraday
said I don't know but someday you may
tax it
our students learn about Maxwell Maxwell
is a theorist and he wrote down with his
Maxwell equations much of what Faraday
did and so they learned about Maxwell
they don't learn about Faraday so much
but Faraday made the essential
contributions and of course Maxwell did
an incredible amount of work but the
relationship between experimentalists
and theorists is complicated and I work
with a lot of experimentalist and that's
why I like this cartoon which says to be
honest I would never have invented the
wheel if it were not for groundbreaking
theoretical work with the circle but I
think the best quote so that you can put
my talk in the proper context is from
our friend Albert Einstein again when he
said the most valuable to of the
theoretical physicist is a spicemaster
thank you very much
I think we still have a few minutes for
questions if there are any
I think that over the years no matter
what anybody did silicon wine you
remember an IBM they were going to use
superconductors for computer using the
Josephson effect and I remember my
colleague at Berkeley John Clark who
works on this and came to me he said
silicon's pass today it's all this and
that the machinery for silicon is
amazing there are so there's so much
invested in equipment in all the rest so
for general applications it looks like
we're gonna have silicon for a while
having said that some of these new
devices that people are making when
grafting are amazing there are people
are using almost a single atom for a
transistor and the fact that graphene
has such high mobility and it's so fast
and all the rest I think it will come up
at the beginning as a material for
special needs just like for
photovoltaics you can get very efficient
photovoltaics and these go into projects
that NASA's involved with where the
usual photovoltaic on your calculator is
amorphous material or something like
that so I'm not really answering your
question but I think in the short term
it's gonna be silicon for a while and
they keep saying it's getting you know
these problems
Moore's law is not going to keep word
well if it's almost worth less not so
bad because we've got all that machinery
Apple keeps making announcements new
things it's gonna be that for a while
but in the long term
these other approaches the nanotubes
also look like they may be useful for
some of these applications in particular
if you take a nanotube and functionalize
it which means you put molecules on the
outside it can detect better than the
nose of the dog molecules that come in
on it so for example for on a regular
watch battery you can build a detective
made out of a nanotube put it on the
wall and it'll tell you how much carbon
dioxide did in this room it will tell
you all kinds of things very simply and
very important for medical applications
with very little power so applications
that we hadn't thought of like we didn't
really know we needed an iPad but
applications that we haven't thought of
these things grafting or carbon
nanotubes aborn nitride nanotubes and
all these new materials like the
workforce you see i talked around bottom
line is i don't know
no no in fact sometimes a great respect
for chemistry I didn't understand it
until I was 50 years old but sometimes
you get the wrong answers back when when
we were doing these things nowadays
everybody gets a right answer from point
of view of starting with orbital theory
and quantum chemistry but for example if
you take gallium arsenide and if you
asked most chemists they would say the
bonding orbitals the valence band of
bonding conduction band anti bonding it
would be out someplace but we know that
the conduction band states are sitting
right on the arsenic atom because we can
calculate we start off totally on
prejudice plane waves they're just
basically constant density everywhere
and we turn the thing on and say now
fine what's going to happen whereas in
the approaches starting with orbitals
you start off with a prejudice it's much
better if you're close because it's much
too bearing you don't have to go through
all of shenanigans we go through in
terms of their shenanigans but there's
nothing you put in I mean there's no
input parameters but so the answer is we
don't use that but they're wonderful
methods and nowadays of both things work
this has nothing to do with relativity
it was basic it's basically an accident
of that you should put something like a
carbon atom in a sp2 orbital and make a
graphene or graphite then the
calculations come out like this and it
was done in the early 1940s calculation
at the Gila University by a theoretical
physicist who certainly would have
shared the Nobel Prize with these people
he had live because he had that I knew
about it as a graduate student you know
so what we were talking about this
afternoon about Exxon Laboratory when
someone took me in and showed me carbon
clusters and said look there's a lot of
them at 66 you while I was doing this
someone said let's go to lunch
and there was the buckyball I mean these
things happen
so here this man actually predicted that
you would have a spectrum that's linear
and it's not relativistic it just looks
the same thing just taking the same so
now people in particle physics are
applying their methods to graphene
because the dispersion relation is the
same but the physics is totally
different this is not a relativistic
calculation
thank you